Louise was just 13 when she became a
victim of online grooming now five years
later she's waived her right to
anonymity to work with the charity safe
and sound and warn others of the dangers
of social media what they do to you they
mentally wreck you you realize in the
end you can't trust anyone
it really did ruin me I thought if I
hadn't have moved on the hand of worked
with these guys I like say what probably
would have killed myself
Louise shares the concerns of the NSPCC
that Facebook's plans to offer
end-to-end encryption on its apps could
allow sex offenders like the ones who
targeted her to go undetected the NSPCC
found a total of nine thousand two
hundred and fifty nine instances
recorded by police where the method of
communication was known almost twenty
two percent were recorded on Instagram
and 19 percent on Facebook only three
percent were recorded on whatsapp which
is already encrypted nearly 57 percent
of the offenses were recorded on other
platforms what's so disturbing about
Facebook's proposals is that really this
means that Facebook sites will become a
one-stop grooming shop the algorithm
will recommend children for groomers to
be able to contact once a groomer has
made that initial contact we know that
then in just a few clicks they'll be
able to start sending encrypted messages
which neither Facebook nor law
enforcement will be able to access
Facebook says it already has systems in
place to help keep young people safe in
a statement the company says there is no
place for grooming or child exploitation
on our platforms we use technology to
proactively remove it and a developing
further ways to detect patterns of
harmful behavior in order to ban and
report those responsible
Lois says she only survived her ordeal
thanks to safe and sound now she's
urging all young people and their
families to use the strongest possible
privacy settings on their social media
and not to be afraid to seek help if
they need to
Fraser Maud Sky News Darby